Why is it so scary?
Welcome back, master and lady.
Hello everybody!
Welcome to Doom 64.
Which I think I'm like...
There's like no place for me to be.
I have to create my own Doomguy head.
In the middle of the screen.
You feeling better?
Actually, I'm feeling like absolute doo-doo today.
I'm feeling quite bad.
But that's okay.
We'll see how far we can get before I'm like, I can't go any longer.
So... no worries.
Interesting choice of words.
What?
You want me to say I feel like shit?
There.
But yeah, playing Doom 64.
Long, long, long, long, long time ago I played Doom 1.
Those VODs are privated though, sorry.
And...
We Wisps are into doo-doo and stuff.
I don't... don't say that.
Don't say that!
What do you mean?
And... I have played Doom 2 before.
So I was just like, I could go into Doom 3.
Or before Doom 3, I could play Doom 64.
Right?
So...
He does not speak for me.
Sure.
Sure, I get it.
I get it.
Who's we?
Hello, Mint Phantom.
Hello.
He speaks only for himself.
If you're feeling doo-doo today, then you might want to take your feet out from there.
Huh?
Might want to take your feet out from there.
Hope you feel better soon though.
Thank you.
Hmm?
Thank you, thank you.
Kiss.
Toot.
Toot!
Membership.
Minto added tax.
Stop!
There's no added tax.
But thank you.
Can't wait to hear the screams.
Yeah!
When I was six, I rented this at the store.
Got scared by a pinky and my mom wouldn't let me get rated M games anymore.
Get revenge for me, Mint.
I will.
I'll get revenge for you.
Let's see.
This is already so spooky, right?
Andragos, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Dogstrings, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you guys so much.
But yeah, I don't feel so well today, so take it easy on me.
We're going to take it easy a little bit as well.
I still, I'm recovering from the big C and jet lag all at the same time.
My mom was just like, hey, can I, can, like, I want to meet up.
But she wanted me to tell her.
She wanted me to test again before I met up with her.
Notorious!
Thanks for the gifted.
And I, I tested two days ago and I was negative, but I think it was a false negative because I tested again two times this morning.
I had COVID still.
Wee!
So I was like, no way.
It's okay, though.
Mm-hmm.
The big C is what Kiara is serving.
Absolutely.
But I feel okay for the most part.
Just, just sometimes my head, I had a really, really, really bad migraine yesterday.
So it's a good thing I didn't stream.
But sometimes I get a little dizzy and sometimes I feel like I'm going to throw up a little bit.
And...
And my nose is a little stuffed.
But other than that, I'm all good.
So my dad played this as a child, but I was always too scared to play myself.
Get revenge for me, too.
I hope you get well soon.
I miss you lots.
Thank you.
You know what?
This, this feels like a game my dad...
Today's Father's Day, isn't it?
This feels like a game my dad would have liked.
But my dad was really into Diablo and Neverwinter Nights.
And I remember gifting him...
Oh, gosh.
There was like...
It was made by this dude.
Diablo People.
I can't remember the name of it, though.
But yeah.
If you celebrate Father's Day, happy Father's Day.
I can be your dad, too.
Oh, Torchlight.
Yes, yes, yes.
Torchlight, Torchlight, Torchlight.
Yeah.
My dad, he also played...
There were some...
I don't think it was Call of Duty, but there were some FPS stuff that he did.
But he never...
I never saw him play Doom.
Not that I can remember.
I don't know.
But yeah.
And he liked Age of Empires and stuff like that.
One of my favorite Doom-like games are Turok games.
Maybe in the future for a filler game especially, too.
Have fun, Mint.
Hope you feel better.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I saw some people in the pre-chat asking about Quake and stuff like that.
Totally not off the table.
Just eventually, whenever I get to it, whenever I feel like it.
Hi, Dad.
Hello, son.
And or daughter.
Hello, child.
Hello, my spawn.
Anyway.
New game.
Happy Father's Day, Daddy.
Be gentle.
Bring it on.
I own Doom.
Watch me die!
What are these?
Dad!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
Don't call them spawn.
Oh, sorry.
Thanks for spawning me.
It's like instead of...
Where are we dropping?
Well, all kids dropped out of somewhere.
Lost in the story.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
So bring it on, would that be normal?
Or I own Doom, is that one normal?
What you do?
Do mods.
Oh, I'm not opposed to it.
I'm not opposed to it.
Sorry.
Time to die.
It's hard mode.
I own Doom as normal.
Bring it on seems like normal.
Okay, we'll do bring it on.
Just like the movie.
Bring it on is normal.
Oh, it's already so spooky.
Why does that look like a trap right there?
What's the music?
I'm scared.
Wait, I'm scared.
I'm the gun.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Maybe I should move myself.
Where can I go?
I'll move right here.
That way you can still see stuff.
But I'm still a little Doom guy head.
Someone got to come out of there?
Beep boop.
I don't want to shoot just to shoot, but...
I know if I go down here...
Ugh.
Oh, I already got the shotgun.
Okay.
I thought it was going to be a trap for sure.
You see that right there?
It's probably one of my friends.
Not
my friends.
Oh, this is just health.
Why is it so scary?
Shoots the friend instantly.
Hold on one second.
I got to fix my screen.
There we go.
One of the big things that separates this from lots of classic Doom is the soundtrack being more horror than heavy metal.
It's very atmospheric.
I'm already getting that vibe.
Is this a door?
No.
Oh, friends.
Oh.
Thank you.
Chew.
What's this?
Is this a door?
I'm guessing space is to open doors, right?
Just like before?
Wait.
How do I actually open the doors?
Sorry.
I did not set up for a stream at all.
Thanks for being our dad.
Of course.
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no.
Eee.
Oh, eee.
Okay.
So let me go back to this.
This is actually so spooky.
What is this?
Oh, box of bullets.
Nice.
I'll take that.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's moving.
I can move with it.
That's so fun.
Oh, I'm moving.
Wow.
That's so cool.
I can't get your bullets.
Nice.
What is...
Do you think I need to do anything with this?
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
It really did work.
Oh, wow.
I think I'm a genius.
Oh.
I got a chainsaw.
Wait.
There was other stuff.
No.
These are just lights.
Okay.
Well...
Oh.
Look at my fist.
I'll go back to the...
Oh, never mind.
I cannot go back to the shotgun.
Okay.
That's a little sad.
That's fine, though.
I'll pack a chainsaw.
I'll skin your ass raw.
They're much pinker in this game.
Shotgun is three.
Oh, thank you.
Not that I don't mind the chainsaw, but the sound of it is a little much, you know?
Oh, there's the blue key.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
I have reflexes.
I like a cat.
I'm picking up stuff first.
Okay.
Never mind.
E.
Oh.
What is that?
What did I just open?
Uh-oh.
What did I just unleash?
Let's see.
The sky is so beautiful.
I hate the moon.
Okay.
Let's go.
Yeah.
I don't know what I just unleashed.
I'm scared.
Anybody else in here ready for a...
Oh.
I hear him.
Somewhere.
I mean, where am I?
Oh, I hear him.
Oh, come on.
I know I'm shotgunning or I'm sniping with a shotgun, but you know, whatever.
What is this?
Maybe it's more health.
It smells minty here.
This is so spooky.
Hope that you start feeling better.
Xen, I get a happy birthday.
Xen, happy birthday.
Singing is not necessary.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
assessments.
Oh my God.
Dharma Michelle.
birthday20 is sad.
Oh, my God.
Happy birthday to you!
Everything's fine, probably.
Do those explode?
Okay.
They do run away.
I do explode.
Good to know.
Freak phantom is about to freak some demons.
Oh, there we go.
Okay...
Oh, do I have to be fast?
Okay, I have to be fast.
Wait a second.
Did I go in here?
Is this new?
Ah!
I think it's new.
Uh-oh.
I heard something big.
Something powerful.
Yellow room... with a pancake.
Gotta go fast.
Chat, is this modded?
It is...
Oh, we're at the very beginning!
It is not modded.
What is that sound?
Oh!
There's a lot more Piggies in here than I thought there would be!
Oh my god.
They can open the door themselves?
Why are you so intelligent?
That's the BGM?
No way.
That was wet.
This is such...
Wowee!
Armor bonus, baby!
The door is squished.
Oh!
Oh, gross!
Wait.
That's nasty.
Oh!
What is that?
Oh no, wait.
Oh, wait.
Is that the real exit?
This is the exit.
Well, hold on, hold on, hold on.
There was another area.
I'm not quite yet ready.
Yeti.
Ah!
Oh!
Um...
I think I found a hidden...
Nice.
I don't know how I found that.
Blueberry!
Wait, where do I get that?
It's showing me...
It's showing me the secret location of a blueberry.
But I don't know how to get it.
What the heck is this game?
There's so much more to explore.
Is it this?
Is this the blueberry?
This must be it.
Berserk!
Um...
Hm?
Anyway...
Nice exploring.
Thanks!
Though...
I don't...
Maybe I guess we just leave.
I do want the blueberry, but...
I guess it's fine.
I don't have to get all the secrets.
And this is kind of easy to get lost here.
I think, maybe.
Where could he be?
Hmm...
You're very close to the blueberry.
Dang!
Ah!
So close.
Zero secrets.
Password?
Entering the terraformer.
No blueberry.
Next time, we'll get him.
Shoot him!
Shoot him when they're not expecting it.
Oh!
That is an imp, right?
I'm assuming...
Is that his butthole?
It's gaping.
It's...
Wow!
Or that's where...
Maybe that's where I shot him.
No!
I think that's his butthole.
Passwords are for area without save.
Hmm...
Do you guys see it?
I don't know.
Or is it just me?
Look!
He's got a gaping hole.
Can I check these?
No.
What the...
The numbers.
What do they mean?
Oh, I need a yellow key.
Oh...
Well...
I...
Oh!
Door.
Are you kidding me right now?
Um...
There must be...
There must be another door somewhere else.
What's that sound?
Can I go through this hole?
Reminds me of laser tag.
Oh my gosh!
I'm...
I'm so terrified though!
Eek!
It's dark!
It's so dark!
Lights.
Oh, thank goodness.
Whoa!
Uh-oh.
I got the mega armor and I unleashed some other people.
Okay.
We have several things that have happened here now.
Oh!
Like that.
Need a blue key.
Okay.
Makes sense.
Blueberry!
Blueberry spotted.
Ah!
This game is so whack!
Uh-oh.
All of these are gonna open, aren't they?
Oh, God.
Who's snoring?
What just happened?
My health didn't go down.
Oh!
That's a different...
That looks like a chain...
Not the chain gunner.
A gun.
Oh my gosh.
Machine gun over there?
Maybe.
There's a zombie above me?
If I shoot...
Dummy.
I'm gonna...
Oh, there's another one.
Oh!
Okay.
Here we go.
I was prepared.
Oh my God.
Don't shoot me.
Can I get him?
Come back over here.
Come back over here, stinky.
I can hear you.
I can hear your mouth breathing.
There we go.
That's what I love about Doom.
You barely have to aim.
Oh!
We're back to normal.
Okay.
Oh!
So, how do I get to the chain?
I'm...
Oh!
Okay.
That's chainsaw.
Is it four?
Yes.
Okay.
No aim required.
Just a little bit of aim required.
I don't want to say no aim.
Tiny, limited aim required.
You know?
What's over here?
Have I gone in?
No.
I have not gone in.
Oh, there's the blue key.
It looks like a trap.
It looks like a trap to me.
It looks like...
Look at that.
They give you literally everything you need.
They're like, you need more armor.
You need more ammo.
You need everything.
You sad, sad.
We'll come back in here.
Hold on.
Oh, gosh.
Where's the blue room?
Okay.
This is...
I know where we are.
So, here...
It's the blue berry.
Is this a staircase?
Yeah.
What is this?
Goggles?
Light amplification goggles.
Oh!
Okay.
I'll take that.
The blue berry is right there, you guys.
Taunting me.
Look at that.
No.
The mood lighting.
Oh, sorry.
Wow.
This game looks so crazy.
Oh, shoot.
I went berserk again.
I went berserk mode.
Hmm.
Here.
Punch the wall.
Red key.
I could have told you that.
The punches are so funny.
I know, right?
Interesting.
Okay.
Oh, the mood lighting really did just...
Oh, this is the blue key.
That's right.
Okay.
I can't even see how far it could go.
Which is over in here.
Alright, let's go into this trap.
Let's fall for it, like the suckers we are, little saps.
What the...
Oy!
Oh.
Huh?
There's puzzles in this game now, too?
I'm too small.
Do you remember what I used to do?
Please!
I don't know how to lift my arms!
Uh-oh.
Wait, those just lifted up, didn't they?
Those were not lifted up before.
Okay.
Interesting.
I don't think it's teleporting again.
Short ghost problems?
Absolutely.
Now we must choose...
Oh no, my goggles!
What was the point of grabbing them?
We have four choices.
How spooky.
Four is my favorite number.
Doomguy Short King confirmed.
We love that for him.
Choose wisely.
This one is the only one without computer.
This one...
Is the...
Yeah, three is the least suspicious, right?
Shark baby!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Oh.
Run!
Oh,
how can I make it faster?
Shift to run.
There is no shift to run.
Hit caps lock.
Oh, wow!
Caps lock.
Oh no, I hit tab.
Oh my goodness.
I didn't realize I was walking this whole time.
Why can he go even faster?
Don't sneak up on me like that.
Look!
It's...
Come on.
Look at that hole.
Zoom.
Holy cow.
Wait.
But space doesn't make me run either.
So I just have to auto run or something, right?
I'm telling you.
I told you.
I saw it the whole time.
That's not for me shooting.
I think they're a little freaky up in here.
It's a little freaky here in hell is all I'm saying.
Okay, we gotta run through this, right?
Okay.
Now I know how to run.
Nice.
Ah!
Have some weird controls because it came from the N64.
Yeah, yeah.
No worries.
So far it's not so bad, I'd say.
Oh my goodness.
Whoa!
Rockets!
What do we need those for?
Uh-oh.
Whoa!
Invisible pinky!
Sounds like my cat snoring.
This is a door.
No, it's not.
We got the blueberry!
Yummy, yummy!
This is definitely a door, though.
This is 100% a door.
Thank you!
I think you're a little freaky.
Can't open it from that side.
Dang.
Okay, well, we also had down here.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
The music makes me so afraid.
The music makes me so scared.
Is this a teleporter?
Oh!
Oh my God!
Whoa!
Ah!
Oh my God!
Wait!
Ah!
I can't see anything!
I think I peed myself.
From the very beginning, y'all.
No!
I lost all my weapons!
Oh my God!
I lost everything!
No!
Also, it looks way darker in OBS than I realize it looks.
It looks way darker in OBS than...
Did I kill him?
Not yet.
Oh my goodness.
Die.
Die already.
Ah, man.
No auto-saves.
No, I'm not playing through OBS.
I just realized.
Oh my God!
Um, I can actually see so much better than I think you guys can.
It's not dark on YouTube?
Oh, okay.
That's good.
You can save manually.
I forgot about this door, to be honest.
Oh, man.
I have to go through everything again.
And I lost my...
Well, I never really used the chainsaw, so I guess it's okay.
Oh, I forgot about this room.
Eek!
Body armor.
And another guy.
Here!
Are there any other guys here?
No.
Grab everything.
I don't want to go berserk.
It's appropriately spooky dark.
I'd say so, too.
And we know how to get to the blueberry.
It's okay.
We lost progress, but...
It wasn't like... it could be where...
Oh!
Where the hell did you come from?
Okay.
I am...
I'm a different ghost now.
I've learned.
Chuu!
Thank you!
Okay.
That's right.
This one.
Battle hardened.
It's very dark on Twitch.
Pure black even.
Except for some white text that says, offline.
Wow.
Offline.
They're...
They're, uh...
They're silencing me.
Oh!
Wait, it's not going in the same order?
Wait.
Am I crazy?
Maybe it is going in the same order.
What?
Is this different now too?
Wait, is this different now also?
No way.
Huh?
I'm being oppressed.
But it's...
This one then.
Oh, shoot.
Where did you come from?
Okay, cool.
Okay.
Blue door.
Blue door leads to blueberry.
Blueberry leads to death.
Ah!
Okay.
Caps lock.
We've been running.
Oh!
Whoa!
That was close.
Ah!
And there's two more here.
And invisible pinky.
Here.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
I'll turn auto run off for now.
Because it stresses me out a little bit.
It makes me be too fast.
You know?
Too fast, too furious.
Oh, but what do I do about the...
Maybe I just shouldn't go in that area.
But I feel like I have to.
Otherwise, where do I go?
What do I do?
You know?
I don't want to go in here!
Hmm...
Otherwise, I need...
Can you save?
Oh, I can!
Save.
Bring it on!
How many levels are there in this game, by the way?
I'm just curious.
When I play these games nowadays, I'm like, what is wrong with the devs making it so hard?
Meanwhile, my goofy ass young Bagger is coming at me.
Then a little easy.
About 25 over 30.
There was like a teleporter over here.
Maybe we should just wait.
No, over here.
Maybe we should just take it.
Right.
This one right here.
Run.
I'm running.
Oh, oh, I'm back at the beginning.
Oh, okay.
I never I didn't get a key or anything like that.
So it's kind of... This is a red key, right?
Yeah.
This version also comes with a new episode.
No way.
Really?
Went down there.
I don't have a yellow key to go in there.
So I need keys.
I only have a blue key.
It's not any of this, right?
Okay.
Thanks, game.
You're so funny.
Okay, game.
It has to be in here.
Oh, shucks.
I think once I... It's this that starts it, isn't it?
I think.
Okay.
Oh, whoopsie.
I think it's that...
I trip that and it all starts coming down.
Stalling pro.
What are you talking about?
I'm just trying to figure out a strategy.
Fine, I'm gonna go.
I made it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Sharp, sharp, sharp.
Try and hit me, stupid imp!
I'll blast you to pieces.
Am I good?
Oh my god, I'm not good.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh no no no no!
Okay.
That was it?
Red key acquired!
Oh, outwards.
I don't like the music.
It scares me.
Okay.
What the hell?
Why didn't that kill you?
I was standing right there.
I should have one-shotted you.
What's going on?
Huh?
I can't leave here.
Oh my god.
Hydraulic press versus made me.
Oh, now I can go.
Okay.
What?
Are you gonna go...
down again?
No?
We're safe?
Maybe?
Safe is not maybe the best word.
We're... Oh, I see you.
I see you down there.
Okay.
Messed up.
Is he still there?
I don't think I can get him from here.
That's okay.
Okay.
Let's just go.
Look at them.
They're in their little cages.
But someone got free.
Okay.
You're stuck in there and I'm not.
This is so freaky.
Why do they have guns in jail?
That's a great question, actually.
That's actually a really good question to ask.
Oh!
The grand...
Oh, I thought...
I thought he was just gonna slide on down.
Got a shotgun.
Hey.
Oh my goodness.
Oh goodness.
From every angle!
Come on!
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Taking out everybody one by one.
Slowly but surely.
This guy too.
There we go.
Okay.
Nice!
264fan here.
Hello!
Alright.
Let's go up here.
Any computers gonna tell me any secrets?
This game is old.
I mean, yeah, it is old.
It's for the N64, like...
Oh!
Goodness gracious.
Aye!
Oh!
Two at once, baby!
Double kill!
I'm too good.
I'm too powerful.
I can't stop.
Probably.
Any secrets?
Okay, I put this down and it's gonna...
Am I running?
Okay, I'm running.
Oh!
Secrets.
Remember to save me, though.
Aki!
Yes.
I turned that.
So, if I go back here...
Aki?
Okay!
I think we can get the heck out of here.
Oh!
Secret area!
I got a box of rockets.
What do I need...
What do I need those for?
Any other secrets?
Secret area...
Nice job!
Thank you!
That's my intuition.
Oh!
This is the other side!
I see.
Isn't this...
Why does this feel longer than going back this way?
Doesn't really feel like a shortcut.
I'd say.
Are you okay?
Even going down the stairs...
Oh, wait!
We can't get back up.
Just kidding.
Yeah, it's okay.
Old N64.
Matt Damon aging gif.
Okay.
This way.
What is that sound?
Sounds like the spider demon.
I think it's just doors closing, but...
Sounds suspicious, you know.
Everything escapes.
Seems suspicious to me.
Wait, how do we get over there?
Right through here!
Oh!
I didn't realize that was the exit.
Yippee!
Only 66 items!
And 50% secrets.
Would love to see Half-Life someday.
Maybe.
I got the password.
Do these passwords change?
Or are they, like...
I mean, like...
Should I be saving them?
Or are they written down somewhere?
I remember playing this game on my brother's 1994 Mac computer.
Holy cow.
Write down the first password?
I think I have it.
Oops.
I think I screenshotted it.
One second.
Yeah, I screenshotted the first one.
The password is only if you're not saving.
Ah!
Okay, then it doesn't really matter.
Also, I'm going to do this real quick.
I was gonna keep myself in a little box.
I mean, I'm still kind of in a little box.
I got a little bit more wiggle room now.
Okay.
Oh.
You guys are right behind me.
I was like, what's attacking me?
I got a super shot!
Nightmare imps.
Not to be confused with, you know, normal ass imps.
Which are not hellish and nightmare-ish enough, I suppose.
Oh!
Hm.
I'm glad.
Oh my goodness!
Ah!
Whew.
He actually got me.
I don't even hear them in there.
Whoa!
Wait, does this one go down?
Oh, it already went down too.
Cool!
Which way shall we go?
I guess this way.
Did I miss my chance?
Um.
Oh, okay.
Actually, I think it was better that I waited.
Wait.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Quit your whining.
I wanna go down here.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, we got the Chaingun!
In 64, you used to have a safe pack like PS1.
PS1's safe cards.
I think the password is in case you didn't have one of those.
Very thoughtful of the devs.
Oh, that's so sweet!
Um.
Let's go down.
Pew!
Pick up all this stuff.
Oh, nice.
Let's go back to the other side.
Shoop!
Pick up everything.
I think we're done in here.
So anyway, I started blasting.
Backpack!
So backpacks allow us to um to hold more stuff.
He turned into spaghetti!
Coco demon!
Why are there more of you?
Why do you have chains?
You little freak!
They don't look so...
They don't look like I remember.
They don't look quite like I remember.
Okay, interesting.
We got two teleporters here.
Oh, secret!
No!
Secret.
Dang.
They look juicy.
Super shotgun double barrel shotguns are my favorite guns to get in old school inspired shooters.
Also, hi Mint.
Hello!
Hello, hello.
Okay.
I guess we'll go through...
Well, now we know that these guys are about...
Oh!
It just leads us to upper level.
Oh.
Oh!
Let me help, please.
Oh.
Okay, so I think both of them are the same, right?
Who's in there?
Oh, no!
What are these guys called again?
Oh, um...
Oh, not...
Revenant's...
Lost Souls!
Lost Souls.
How do I get down?
Oh, wait.
Right here?
Oh.
Do I need to...
Do I need to run into it?
No revenants in here?
Wait, in this game?
Or...
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Yellow key!
Did we see a yellow door?
I don't think I saw one.
Did I?
Am I just blind?
I don't remember seeing a yellow door.
Do you guys?
The very star.
Was this not the very star?
The blue key area had another door.
This one?
This seems quite yellow.
Back to the blue key room.
Okay, let me go back.
Oh, I thought you meant like...
That, as in...
The room that we used.
Oh my god, again?
Why are you respawning?
Hahaha.
A rocket launcher!
Oh, this door.
I see it.
I don't even notice it.
Thanks guys.
It's a lot of armor and a lot of health.
Wait, which button is...
Okay, five.
Four.
A three.
Happy Father's Day.
Since I don't have a dad, can you guys be my dad?
Okay, let me...
Oh my goodness, the glasses!
Easy peasy.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Hahaha.
Stop playing game and clean your room.
Oh my gosh, stop.
Oh, Hi Pies!
She's in here with me.
She might want out though.
Okay, I guess we just go down.
What did that open?
Oh!
A box of rockets!
Let me out.
Oh!
What was that over there?
Oh, I saw that open up.
I saw right here it opened up.
Can I do it again?
Must have been the wind.
Haha.
If I go...
Wait, eh?
I'm so confused right now.
Try going in the door.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Run!
Ah!
No!
The little thing that would let me go inside disappeared too quickly.
Okay, hold on.
Run!
Am I running?
I am.
Okay.
I gotta be so speedy though.
Also, what is...
I guess that one is already activated.
Oh!
What the...
I'm so confused.
Jump?
There is no jump in this game.
There is no jump in Doom.
Come on!
Ah!
I got it!
Secret aerial!
Blast in his ass.
Nice!
We got it.
But actually I do need a red key, don't I?
So...
Um...
I do actually need a red key.
Where do I get that from?
Hmm...
This one is already activated.
This one only opens this door.
Hmm...
Right?
Blue key room again?
Oh!
Who keeps placing stuff here?
Okay.
Who keeps putting stuff in there?
Exit already?
Yippee!
That's okay.
I'm not gonna get all the secrets.
Oh my god!
Only 20% of secrets though!
That's pretty...
That's pretty crazy.
Um...
One second.
Ahem.
Holding area.
You guys...
Um... be honest with me, though.
Are you able to see all right and everything?
Because I can turn up the brightness if you guys need it.
And holding area.
Doom 64 levels were... big on what?
Shifting little bits around and changing the layout, adding items that weren't there before.
That's so cool because it makes you want to explore even more.
Oh my goodness!
Oh my god, he was actually invisible!
That's crazy.
Are all the same monsters and stuff from Doom prior in...
...this as well?
Or is there any new guys or anyone missing?
No,
no, there's a few missing.
Who's missing?
Please tell me it's the jockey skulls.
They're the ones I hate the most.
Oh wait, why am I picking these up?
It's not doing anything.
Chain gunner?
No chain gunner?
For real?
I was wondering where those guys were, to be honest.
Is that a berserk thing?
How do I get to it?
Wait, actually I don't...
Oh.
Oh!
Secret.
Okay.
No skeleton boys, if that helps.
Really?
Flashing lights warning soon.
Oh, thank you.
ViviCore, thanks for the gift!
Did?
Why is the blueberry just right there?
Oh!
Woah!
Oh my god, thank you for the warning!
Fla...
Flashing...
Flashing lights!
Oh jeez!
Oh god!
Oh, it was such a bait!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Ahhhh!
Turn it off!
Anything!
Please, turn it off!
Oh, hello imp.
Wow!
Hello imps!
Imp party!
What's in here?
Oh!
How do I get that?
Oh my goodness.
It's over now.
Thank goodness.
That was pretty...
Regular imps.
Um, so no chain gunners.
Um, wait!
Barons were the, um...
Were the, uh...
What's the words?
I want that.
There are barons of hell here, yes.
Okay, okay, okay.
Barons are in this game.
But those are not the skelly guys.
Those are like the big guys that look like, um...
That look like, you know...
Like a stereotypical demon.
Okay, this seems like I'm activating a maze of some sort.
Like I'm lifting walls and moving some things around.
Or maybe not.
Maybe I should just activate all of them.
I'm not quite sure actually.
I don't know what's going on.
The big goatman.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
How do I get...
He's floating in the sky.
He's floating.
Knights and barons, aka bigger imps.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh!
It's just...
Oh my goodness.
Oh.
Hello.
It just flew me off.
I didn't even mean to come down here.
Are there...
Um...
Meatball guys?
I can't remember what they're called either.
The uglier cocoa demons?
How do I get up?
Just like that?
There we go.
Pain elementals!
Yes.
So I really only remember Pinky.
Pinky...
Where was the blue door?
I don't think I remember seeing it.
What's this door?
Oh!
I didn't know he could get me from up there.
I can get him...
Two!
I thought I heard another guy...
Imagining it, perhaps?
The super shotgun uses two, right?
We can shoot one that switches.
Oh!
I can shoot that one!
Oh.
I didn't know if it would be a waste.
Oh!
That's fun.
And I activated something.
Oh, there we go.
Now I'm in the zoo.
Yeah, I discovered...
I realized what it did like as soon as I did it.
Silly me.
It's okay though.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh!
God!
Where did you come from?
Good Lord!
Goodness gracious!
Scared the heck out of me.
It's just a skelly man.
Hmm...
How do we get that other...
Oh!
Hey, buddy.
All right.
We got lots of switches around here in this game.
Oh, no!
It's these guys!
Ow!
The goats!
Oh, my goodness.
They're strong.
Uh...
Four.
Ah!
Goats!
The goats!
Anyway...
Oh!
No.
I'm in the prison.
Don't forget your rocket launcher.
Oh, you're right.
I do have that.
Is this real?
Chat!
Oh, no.
I'm not quite done yet.
Oh!
Ow!
God!
I wish I were done.
There was one more.
At least.
There.
Interesting.
Do I run across those?
But how do I get up there?
See you later.
Bye.
Secret.
Oh!
Blueberry!
I'm a bit of a genius.
Ah!
I got it!
Yippee!
Tensai.
Oh, so I can't get over there now, though.
You have to...
Oh!
Okay.
Someone was saying that I can't get to that secret area because I guessed wrong.
Oh, man.
Well, I got this secret area.
Oh!
I'll take the second one at least.
By punching a wall.
I failed the puzzle.
How was I supposed to know?
Oh, well.
Yippee!
Ninety-five.
Well, for hell!
Thanks for the ten gifts!
I got some...
Ow!
Some things.
Edamame from... basically before I left Japan, because I couldn't do anything, on my last day, right before I left, I went to Don Quixote, and I went to a couple, like, um, konbini, and I was like, I'm just buying all the snacks.
I couldn't buy anything else.
My suitcases were so empty, so I just bought a bunch of snacks.
And now I'm eating them.
And these ones are really good.
I've never had these edamame ones, but I thought they would be, like, the bean part.
But they're actually quite, um, they're quite fluffy.
Of course I got jelly.
Ewww!
Oh wow.
It's red, yellow.
Let's save.
Get down.
I almost feel like maybe I should have gone harder.
Well, that's okay.
It's been a while since I've played Doom, so...
It's fine if I'm, you know, on a little bit of an easier level, I suppose.
Oh, um, hmm.
Hmm.
Gets a bit nastier later.
I believe you.
Blue?
Um, is this the door?
Oh, yes it is!
Absolutely!
Yeah, you tried.
You tried.
Nope.
Hmm.
This one?
No.
How do I get you?
Just reach out and grab it, Doomguy!
Use your arms!
You have...
I clearly have some!
Hold on.
I'll punch the yellow key.
I love not having to aim in these.
I know, right?
It's such like a...
It...
Wow.
Look at...
Why does...
The chandelier is so fancy in there.
My baby arms.
Okay.
What is...
Oh my goodness!
It's a party!
Okay, so yellow key in here.
Whatever the hell that is in there.
I think there was a door.
Oh, wait.
We haven't gone down here yet.
Oh.
Lost souls.
Ugh.
Oh my god, please.
The lost souls look cooler in this game, actually.
They look quite neat.
I like them.
I'm grabbing health and it's not doing anything.
But I can grab more armor.
That's always a thing.
Okay.
I don't see a switch.
Paint elementals do too?
Okay.
I'm looking...
Because those guys look goofy as hell in the original.
Paint elementals look so dumb.
It's really funny...
Watching...
What's the word?
Yippee!
It's really funny seeing like Doom Eternal and stuff because I don't recognize...
I'm like, wait...
That's so and so?
I'm like, wait, that's a pinky?
Oh my goodness.
Ouch!
I got caught by just a grunt.
Be careful who you make fun of in middle school.
Just like that for Doom 3.
Just goofy looking idiots.
Idiots.
Oh my goodness!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Why these guys are doing the most damage to me?
It's a little frustrating.
Nice!
Are there any secrets here?
Secret...
I'm hacking?
Sometimes they really try to get me.
Okay, that just goes back down I suppose.
Imp?
Hacking?
Dan!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I got a shotgun.
Oh, super shot!
I already had that though.
That's okay.
Thank you for the meal.
Ew!
Oi!
Oh this is what happens when I click this.
And then in here was a whole lot of nothing.
Ugh.
Okay.
Okay, let's head back.
Um, this room was also empty...
that I know of.
Hmph!
There was a door up top.
There was?
Was I blind?
Up here?
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Sometimes I can be a little blind.
What did that open?
Here's the question.
What did it open?
To be fair, the doors are very similar colors.
Sometimes I'm just not looking for it, you know?
I mean, I should be.
I'll get better about it, I think.
Eventually.
Maybe in here?
No?
Down in here?
And here?
No?
And... here?
Something change?
You?
Aha!
Yellow key!
It's dog!
Armogaren!
Welcome back!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Or welcome.
Blueberry!
That door is a little bit aggressive.
The wriggling flesh mounds are just a little...
A little gross.
Doomguy too thick.
Doomguy... These bars are like 10 feet apart.
We're just...
We're just that...
We're just that thick, man.
Um...
What did that open?
Oh!
Blueberry!
Blueberry secrets!
Secrets!
Hmm...
What did it open?
We went down here before, right?
What's in here?
Nothing.
Have we gone here?
Yes.
What?
I don't recognize these walls at all.
That's some dude named David Hayter yesterday.
He was talking about you?
No, he wasn't.
Stop it.
Is this new?
No.
Where do I go?
I can never tell what...
Where something will activate.
I can never tell.
He is a wisp.
Press the button...
And it activated.
What?
Map?
Uh...
I hate...
I'll be honest, I hate the map in Doom.
I hate the map in Doom.
Because... what does this even mean, first of all?
But second of all...
I hate that if I'm checking other places on the map, I have to move with the map.
Like, for instance, if I'm just like, oh, what's this?
Like, I'm now here, you know?
I don't like that.
You can zoom out with Q and R.
I do like, though, that it's...
That it is kind of like...
Oh, let's check that area.
It is kind of... it's colored based on the...
Yes, there we go.
Based on the room.
Ooh, that was loud.
Because it helps a lot, actually.
Uh-oh.
Another...
Another maze.
But that does help me.
I don't want to go berserk.
I'm not ready to go berserk.
Boo-boo-boo.
I'll take that.
Ouch-ah!
Oh,
this is not real.
This sure is a maze-y maze.
Yes, indeed.
I'll turn around, bozo.
Oh, come on.
That's totally something.
We're activating so much of the system.
So much stuff.
Real fake doors.
That's why.
These are going to be... I was going to say these will be the end of me.
But they have already been the end of me.
And they sound so squishy every time.
I remember there was a secret.
I don't want to test every single one though.
But sometimes these walls open up.
Oh my god!
No, no, no!
Please!
I was walking!
I got stuck on the wall!
No!
Hmm.
Squish ASMR.
Okay.
Where am I?
Ah!
I know where we are!
Actually, that's so funny.
I know because of this corner.
Yes.
Okay.
Where...
Oh my god.
Crushers equal minty ectoplasm.
Yeah, I remember because I tried that light.
Here?
Is this open now?
Is this all fine and dandy?
Oops.
Meatball.
No, that's not the meatball yet even.
We haven't even reached full meatball.
Don't worry.
We'll get there.
How do I get the blueberry?
Somehow.
Look at this eye!
Oh my god!
It's so gross!
It's so nasty.
Oh!
See that?
And the blue key is in there.
Oh my goodness.
Are you kidding me right now?
Wait, I can stand inside, can't I?
Oh, there's nothing in here though.
Woo!
Yeah.
Come at me.
Try again.
Stupid lost souls.
Well done.
Thank you!
Welcome back from Apkai.
Your summer podcast episodes have been keeping me sane the past few weeks of finance work.
Thank you!
Thank you for listening!
I'm so happy!
Thank you!
What did I pick up?
The blue key.
Whoa!
A soft, a soft mumble in my ear.
A little...
I heard it.
Imp ASMR!
Yeah.
It's exactly what it was.
I saw this one.
These screens must tell me the truth of the blueberry.
I'll never know.
I wonder if I can blow some of them up.
If that will do anything.
I'm gonna test all these, sorry.
Now that I know sometimes they'll tell me things, I have to always...
Oh, what's that?
Hmm?
Oh, I hear another growl.
Huh?
What did that do?
It turned on and off immediately.
DoomShotties always hit so good.
I know, right?
You can even snipe with them, basically.
It's great.
I can still hear it in here.
Hmm.
Okay, well I guess we'll go through here.
Nevermind.
Hello?
Uh-oh.
I need a shotgun emote.
YouTube might get mad at me for that.
They might be like, um, what do you need that for?
Don't worry about it.
Bubble tea!
Oh my goodness, I wish I could get some bubble tea.
What?
Maybe it works now?
What am I missing here?
I thought... oh, I thought, like...
This was, like, connecting to it somehow.
It turns off immediately.
It's a time switch.
Yeah, but for what?
Is it timed for this?
Oh!
Oh, I see, I see it.
Okay.
Oh, that was a quick... that was really fast.
We're back in business, baby.
Okay, that doesn't open quite yet.
Woo!
Get out of my way.
Who's behind here?
Who's in here?
Uh-oh.
Coco demon!
Demon!
Eww.
It's supposed to be a fast-paced game.
I know.
I know that I don't go at the right doom pace, okay?
But I'm a cautious... I'm a cautious ghost.
Can you blame me?
Oh, this probably... now I probably have to go back.
There we go.
Oh.
Exit!
All about tactical espionage action.
Only 93% kills?
But I got all the secrets.
Interesting.
Makes the game more atmospheric.
I'm not quite, um... doom guy, you know.
That guy goes in and he's just like, boom, bam, bam, boom.
But for me, I'm just like a little baby.
Hmm.
Oh my god.
Eww.
Ah!
That guy was really gonna come up on me!
Oh shit.
Uh...
Four.
There we go.
Okay.
Take him down!
Hell Knight.
Oh, I need a yellow key for this.
Oh, a hero.
Okay.
I heard him grunting over there.
Nasty.
Whoop!
Yeah, yeah, mister.
Oh, shit.
Hi, Mint.
Hello!
Oh.
That actually took quite a bit of my health.
That wasn't so great.
That was not so good.
Ouch-a!
I hear them.
I hear them from beyond the walls.
Ah!
Oh!
They're everywhere!
Oh my god.
Shoot.
Get
them all at once!
Oh my god.
Ah!
Bloop!
Uh-oh.
The moles in hell.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Ah!
He's gonna come around the corner any second.
Oh!
Oh, my god!
I
hope this isn't a waste.
Oh, wait.
That's just an imp!
Sorry, mister imp.
I kind of took...
I kind of really overkilled you.
Sorry, mister imp.
Imp evaporate.
They all come from everywhere.
Where?
How do I get back up there?
Up here?
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
That imp had a bad day.
I'm having a bad... They're all ganging up on me like crazy.
Like the... I feel like the difficulty went from 0 to 100 all of a sudden.
There's still more.
I can't even explore the area.
I'm just like... I'm just a kill... Look at all this.
This is a bloodbath.
I'm just a killing machine.
Wow.
Wait.
This is the one...
Which one does this?
I can't remember.
Just you wait.
Oh man.
Yeah, I hear you.
I hear... Actually, I don't remember.
What's the pink one for?
It's so cute.
Oopsie.
Okay.
Let's go back.
You jerk!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh...
Yeah, Loki!
Oh, that was... There was the one that we couldn't get.
There was like a... From the main area, there was a little lever that we couldn't pull.
This area is such a maze though.
I'm getting so lost.
I'm getting so lost right now.
Did I grab everything in here?
I think so.
Everything that I could.
Yeah, switch back at the beginning.
Yes, yes, yes.
Well, there's some... There's a lot of health around here in case we need it, so...
Oh.
This way.
It was up there, right?
I still haven't even gotten up here.
What's in here?
Oh, this is the entrance.
Where I started, I think.
Oh.
Rip Megasphere.
We'll go back.
Wait.
This is where I just came from.
See, I'm so lost.
It's okay.
Okay.
Oh.
It's timed.
I have to find the secret, though.
Yeah.
Who was that?
You.
Okay.
Let's go back and see if we can find the secret.
Oh.
Wait.
It opened up, though.
It was just open.
Shinzou, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Cheeky shot.
Maybe I have to do it on the way down?
Ah.
Hmm.
I saw it open, though.
I saw it open.
Goodness.
Oh.
Go further out of the corridor, then come back.
Okay.
Like this way?
Then come back?
Ah!
Thank you!
Oh.
Dang.
I really thought it was going to lead to...
to the... to the... other sphere.
The non... the pearl.
The non-blue... where was that, anyway?
I can't... I can't even...
Oh, I found it!
Meow.
I found it!
We'll see if you can find the secret.
I knew where it was.
All along.
Hehehe.
Err.
The Jawbreaker...
The Jawbreaker?
Meow.
Okay.
When this comes down...
Hmm.
Well.
How do I...
Get over there?
The Eddie O.V.
Derp.
Don't call me that!
Are
we missing something?
Perhaps.
I don't think it's a speed thing.
Because I can't even get around it until it goes down.
And by the time it goes down, this is already up, right?
Like how I sometimes just incidentally run into some of these things.
That was close.
We straight up drifted across there.
That was kind of crazy.
I don't think I can get that guy.
But I can get that guy.
I'm just stumbling my way through here.
It kind of...
It feels like with Metal Gear how they're just like...
Solid Snake was so good at his job.
When a lot of the times he was just like...
He was just kind of like...
What's going on?
Ow!
Oh my god!
He was just kind of in the right...
Right place at the right time.
Come here.
I don't even want to die.
Jumper!
Die already!
I hear the Pinkie.
I see him.
I see the Pinkie.
Come here, Pinkie.
Come here.
Come over here.
There we go.
Okie dokie.
Good stuff.
I picked up a box of showers.
Pinky pop a hippo bar.
Box of rockets.
Open up.
Come on!
Open up!
Give me the stuff!
Press the doom button to doom all over your foes.
Doom!
Nasty.
Stop!
Open up something.
Open up that area.
Is there another guy in here?
No.
Where did you come from?
There's more of them.
I see what it is!
It's a paint elemental!
Oh my god.
Look at him from here.
Wait, I kind of want to see.
I want to see him though.
Woah!
He kind of looks awesome!
He kind of looks awesome though.
Did I kill him?
I can't tell.
Spice to meet the bow.
I'm always in the wrong place the right time.
We know.
Oh!
Hi Huey.
Huey.
Where
am I hearing it from?
Where am I hearing it from?
Where
am I hearing it from?
I
think it's the last one.
Now I can't see nothing.
Hold on, let me...
I will turn up the display.
No, we don't need it any more than that.
Overall brightness.
That's as max as it can go.
I can turn up environmental brightness.
Maybe that will be better.
Oh my god.
There's so many in here.
There's so many invisible pinkies in here.
I don't want to go berserk.
How do I get out of here?
Spooky!
Stairs on the wall.
How can you guys see better than me?
Better than I can.
Stairs on the wall?
This?
How am I supposed to go up it though?
Oh!
What?
It's like the smallest...
Huh?
Wow!
How the hell am I doing this?
I think I'm...
Oh my god I can kind of see them now.
What the hell?
What are these?
These stairs are for...
the thinnest person alive.
Legs of a mountain goat.
Exactly!
What is this for real?
Hahaha!
Actual legs of a mountain goat.
Okay hold on.
I don't want to quite do that yet.
Can't go in there.
Okay.
But there was a door...
That door over there.
No wonder everybody is dead here!
Okay never mind.
That is not a door.
This seems to...
Hmm.
How do I get to the blueberry?
Hmm hmm hmm.
Indeed.
Ah!
Huh.
Good thing there is no fall damage.
It's just...
It's just horribly obnoxious.
Okay I'm going to go through this one.
Oh it took me back to here.
Okay.
Alright.
We running.
Run!
Just run!
I don't know what I did.
It's so bright now.
I can turn it down.
It looks all the same for me.
It truly only looks different.
In...
In OBS which is so strange.
Hmm.
Do I go back down there now?
Let's try this one.
Oh!
They are both the same.
How do I blueberry?
Well I don't really need it.
But I kind of just want it.
You know?
Hmm.
Kind of just want it.
Just to have it.
You know?
Hmm.
Am I trapped here?
I'm picking up stuff that I don't need.
But that's okay.
Oh!
Oh.
I needed that.
Very nice.
Smallest, thinnest walls in history.
Someone said...
Try running off into the...
the side into the room.
But like there's a...
There's like...
There's no way to get into it.
And then also there's stuff in here.
There's so much stuff!
I also need to get the blue...
Oh.
Dang it.
Maybe it's open now.
Oh come on.
The button room.
You can get it from the top.
I can.
Hold on.
So why would you go up...
after I leave the platform?
Oh there it is.
It is open.
Look at that.
Would you look at that.
From the button room.
I can make it.
Ah!
Wow!
Let's see.
Is there a secret door?
I feel like...
so blind in this.
Too used to the convenience of...
modern game design.
I did not mean to press that.
My fingers slipped...
as I was drinking my tea.
Now we're back.
Oh!
I think I need to run off here.
Okay.
I understand.
I see.
I understand now.
Maybe from like here?
There we go.
Okay.
Then from there.
Oh!
It opens up the door over there.
Ah!
Let's go back up the stairs.
Oh!
It was timed.
There we go.
Huh!
Yeah!
Blah!
Oh!
Come on!
Blah!
What the heck?
Why could I do it first time before?
And now...
She got it first try to never get it again.
There we go.
Now, run.
But don't fall.
Run!
Yippee!
What did that do?
Wait, maybe that opens for the armor?
Maybe?
Yippee!
Oh.
Too good at this game.
I'm too good at this game.
Well, we know where it is if we need it, you know?
Okay, blue key, blue door.
Right here.
Okay.
Finally.
Back to killing things.
Oh god!
Why did it have to be you?
Three of them!
This is so unfair.
Oh, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
I think it's because you're playing literally on...
What?
No, everybody said this was normal.
What are you talking about?
Everybody said this was normal.
63%, 66% secrets.
What did I miss?
Hmm.
What's that?
Is the BFG in this game?
Red key, yellow key.
It is?
Oh, I should save.
Hmm,
hmm.
Hmm.
Wow, exactly...
Oh my goodness!
Ah!
Well, I had exactly enough...
To be...
Full health.
Dang.
You kept us waiting but you returned to doom hell.
Rip and tear until it is done.
Rip and tear!
I hear another guy.
He's snoring.
I hear him.
I don't even stand a chance.
Woo!
Oh, wait.
Save some of that.
What's wrong with this room?
Oh.
Oh!
Area map!
Yippee!
Hahaha!
Today is my birthday!
Wait, who sent that?
Okay!
Happy birthday!
Moppy!
Oh my god, that's a throwback.
Hahaha!
Moppy!
Throwback to that time.
I played...
Doom and I couldn't read.
Oh!
Oh yeah...
What's this?
I was gonna say, did I go in here?
I was gonna
say, did I go in here?
All these poor little scientists.
All these poor little nerds.
I'm guessing they're scientists.
You know?
Okay, so this is where I...
Yes.
That's what it showed me in the...
Oh!
Yeah!
Hahaha!
Wait, can I not reopen it?
No!
Blueberry!
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
More marines just not as cool as you.
Got it.
No way!
Yay!
Literally blue balled.
Don't say that.
Shoot the switch.
I wonder if I can redo it.
Hahaha.
I can't remember where I've been.
Oh!
That opened something.
In here?
No.
This is where...
I just came from.
I'm so lost.
I don't remember.
I don't remember at all.
Oh well.
That's okay.
I don't need the blueberry so much anyway.
Oh wait.
Oh yeah, see it's still activated.
That's okay.
Here's the map.
What was the special map that I got?
What even does it...
What's its purpose?
Oh!
I want that.
Well, I don't need it right now.
But I want it.
Ah!
Switch?
Not a switch.
Maybe a switch.
Punch the switch.
Shoot the switch.
I can't read maps.
It's true!
Actually.
Thank you very much.
This is the most...
You can read this?
What does it mean?
Here we go.
Flashing lights.
Oh my god.
Jump scared by his booty.
Wait, the exit!
Oh, it's right there.
I need a yellow key.
There's so many things we need.
Okay.
Cake scare.
Good morning!
Okay, so we need the red key for both of these then.
Got it.
Oh!
We're right here.
Where we...
Huh?
Wait, what is that showing?
Oh!
Okay.
It's showing that room.
God.
What a tease.
What an actual tease.
I can't go through here yet.
Oh, I can go through here!
That guy is mashing interact on the secret rooms of my heart.
Ah!
Oh shoot.
Oh my god!
Where the hell did you come from?
New weapon.
This is the plasma gun, isn't it?
From hell?
Duh.
Duh-beem.
Yellow key.
Who is grunting?
All I can hear is grunting everywhere.
Chuu!
I gotta do an early stream for my favorite series.
I just got off work.
Sorry!
Um...
Wait.
I needed the yellow key.
In here, right?
That's because it's the weekend.
I tend to do earlier streams on the weekend.
It's all...
Okay.
Yellow.
Is this also yellow?
Nope.
Okay.
Mr. Snoring up in here.
Gosh.
This game is so...
Stinky!
Who is snoring?
Is it you?
Have you been snoring this whole time?
Have I been in here?
Uh...
This is where I...
Oh...
Wait.
Yes.
Is stinky a good thing?
Yeah.
It's like a...
You!
When I get my hands on you!
Kind of feeling.
Energy...
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I need for the gun.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
So much.
Losing health like crazy.
Okay.
This is where we came from.
Sorry.
I'm a bit lost if you couldn't tell.
Oh my god.
I'm...
Trapped?
Maybe I don't need to use the giant...
Whatever's for that guy.
But...
It's fun to use the rocket launcher.
Hmm.
Why are you grunting?
Over what?
Uh oh.
We can't go in here.
Hmm...
Can I walk along the walls?
I can.
Nice.
Oh.
I could have just literally taken the stairs.
Hahaha.
I could have literally taken the stairs.
But...
That's okay.
We have the...
Where haven't we gone?
What's that red...
Red bit?
Right there.
Oh.
That's the exit.
Um...
What the?
Oh.
Don't scare me like that.
Remember to...
Yes.
Thank you.
Where haven't we gone?
Obviously past those bars.
Um...
Showing the blueberry on the map.
So evil.
Oh.
Goodness.
Take that.
We've pressed that.
Where haven't we been?
Hmm...
Pressing F might help you move freely?
No.
I don't think so.
Worth a shot though.
Maybe I have to go up to those bars?
Hmm...
What was that teleporter over there?
There was a switch.
Not sure if you shot it already.
Wait.
The one that I tried to shoot and it wouldn't let me?
Um... Where was it?
Back through here?
I think?
Can't do this.
Huh.
Through here?
I got both of these.
What was through here?
Oh yeah.
That's right.
It took me to this switch.
And then...
The bars and the acid.
Yeah.
That's the only thing...
I can think of to try.
Going to.
Oh!
They open.
What?
They're trying to close.
Don't close on my head, please.
Okay.
Nice.
So...
Don't forget to save.
You're so right.
Oh my gosh.
I should totally save right here.
You're so right.
Okay.
Oh!
No!
Hahaha!
Oh!
There's a door right here.
Are you kidding me?
Oh!
My eyes!
It would not be a Doom game if not for just some bullshit like this.
Oh my goodness.
Ah!
I could really use a blueberry right now.
Hahaha!
Is that everything?
Did something secret elf went up over here?
No?
Okay.
Let's get out of here.
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Are you guys okay?
Can we see?
Are we still alive?
Well, I've never been...
Oh my god!
I can't see anything!
Ah!
Okay.
Let's just close our eyes until it's gone.
We're good.
It's probably lowered the things in here?
Yes.
All according to
Where was the red door at?
Oh, it was the environmental brightness.
Oh, my bad.
Was it under display?
No, I didn't.
I raised it.
I lowered it.
I didn't raise it that much.
Well, that should be better.
Okay.
Red door.
Is this what happens when you do the do?
Actually.
Real doing the do footage.
Where was the red door?
There are red switches.
There are?
I'm looking.
Is it that over there?
Is it secret?
No.
Secret?
Actually, I have no idea.
I don't know where to go.
Yellow?
In here?
I think?
And then in here?
Nope.
Just kidding.
This way?
This one?
I still can't touch this one.
This is...
Oh, this is what I just got.
Okay.
This leads back to the green.
In here.
Oh!
I don't see any in here.
Hold on.
I'm checking the map.
Where did I miss a switch?
You passed the switches.
I did?
Here?
Why can't I see anything?
Is there any chance of you playing the ROM hack Doom?
Someday.
It's really good.
Maybe.
Oh!
I forgot.
I forgot that I didn't press those.
Because they were lit up, I thought that I had pressed them.
How do I get back there?
Oh, shoot.
Here?
Get me in there.
Oh, okay.
I just needed to press one of them.
There we go!
25% secrets.
Hmm...
Entering the final outpost.
Oh, I love them.
Oh, my memory.
What a jerk.
Oh.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, my goodness.
Can I shoot some of these guys?
Maybe with a...
Find someone who loves you as much as Doomguy loves oofing his walls.
I can't tell if they're...
If it's ambiance I'm hearing or...
Wow, this is kind of...
Oh!
Oh, that was close.
Hey!
Where are you?
Did I get him?
I can't tell.
I can't tell at all.
That's okay, though.
Okay.
Saving the game.
Oh, my God.
There's so many sounds.
Spooky!
Got the chaingun again.
This goes the same way.
Okay.
So this is where I just killed all those guys.
Yep, yep, yep.
Umm...
It makes me feel good.
Yeah, I'm a safe scummer.
What of it?
What are these sounds?
I think I got him.
Yep.
Sometimes I feel more safe with the chaingun and sometimes I feel more safe with the shotty.
Okay.
They could have limited your saves if they were really worried about it.
Sometimes it's so hard to tell if an older game is going to be nice to you or not.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes they're just like...
Sometimes they're like...
Yeah, we'll give you all this nice stuff.
Sometimes they're just evil.
Okay, so we don't have a blue key.
Let's keep going.
I gotta make it really hard so that you don't just... Okay.
What's gonna happen here?
Oh!
What I do like about the chaingun is it does kind of stun them for a second.
So they can't really like do much.
What am I hearing?
Is it the spider?
Is it ambience?
I can't tell at all.
What's going on?
Spooky BGM.
It's really spooky.
Yay!
Oh no!
Uh oh.
Blue.
Blue water.
Oh!
Nice!
Secret.
The blood made it...
Where am I supposed to go from here?
Actually.
Uh...
Hacking?
Actually he won't...
He doesn't want to hack this wall.
I don't like the music at all.
It's making me really paranoid.
It's making me super ultra paranoid.
I'm so scared right now.
Okay.
I guess I'll flip this switch.
Oh!
Oh my health!
I could use a blueberry right now.
Why did my health go down so much?
When my armor was at max.
It's kind of messed up.
Okay.
Box of bullets.
There's lots of armor in here.
Which is nice.
They literally phased into existence!
They didn't even come from anywhere!
They didn't even come from behind a wall!
They just...
Ghost men.
Yeah!
They lined up for me though.
So true.
I hear them.
Oh!
Oh shit.
Oh I'm gonna run out of bullets at this rate.
Yikes.
Yikes!
Rocket launcher!
Maybe I should have used that.
That's fine though.
More shotgun shells.
Box of rockets.
Ow!
Shit.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Okay.
We're full on rockets.
She's so clutch.
Am I though?
My health.
I need a blueberry.
I need a blueberry!
Where was the red door anyway?
Oh.
Wait.
Hold on.
Maybe we haven't seen it yet.
You mean I'm scared to hold my hand please?
Okay.
Give me your little quivering baby hand.
It's so small.
I could fit like five of your hands in my hand.
What'd that do?
It was something timed.
But I'm not quite sure what.
I'm not quite sure what that does yet.
Oh.
There's red.
Right there.
Okay.
So do I teleport here?
No.
Oh!
It turned berserk!
Look at that.
Will this give me extra health?
No.
I just can't see.
Daniel!
Thank you for the Hawkeye Super!
I never thought too bad your trip to Japan wasn't very good.
But here's some funds for the next one.
Hopefully we'll be better.
Missed you a lot.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
I'm getting deja vu.
I don't know about you.
Gotta wait for that to go back down, right?
Oh.
There we go.
Like so.
Okay.
Hmm.
I like how there's like more ambient lighting and everything.
It's pretty fun.
And the music has basically stopped.
Okay.
Nevermind.
It's back.
How
do I get to the red over there?
Yeah.
There was this room.
I completely forgot about it.
I don't know.
Do I?
I'm lost again.
Let's see.
Wait.
There's a bunch of yellow switches over there.
Did I not...
Did I not see them before?
Or...
In here?
Oh.
I think it's just...
They're just showing me what the computers are.
Okay.
You winning, dear Minty?
I think so.
Probably.
How do I...
get up there?
There was like a... I need to get over there.
Because there was a staircase that leads down to the red room.
Hmm.
Have you played the other Dooms before?
I have!
I've played one and two before.
So I'm playing this one before I play three.
It's the Minto guy.
So teleporter...
Like I don't think...
I can't go through there, right?
Nope.
Oh.
And I lost my chance to go through here too.
There's nothing here?
Ugh.
This blue stuff does hurt me though, right?
I'm not dumb, right?
Might be a time switch that lets you in with the teleporter.
Oh.
Three is different.
Cool.
But cool and has great spooky atmosphere.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
It doesn't hurt me.
Sorry.
Like I said, it's been a while since I played, you guys.
Okay?
I can't remember what's good and what's against me, okay?
I just assume everything is...
Oh.
Dang.
Wait.
Maybe...
Oh!
That must go down!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I just assume everything is against me.
Yay!
Okay.
I figured it out, everybody.
Ugh.
Wait, so is this the Hell Knight or is this the Baron?
I can't remember which one's cooler.
Pew!
Weaker is Hell Knight.
What the?
I have to like time it perfectly.
Maybe.
Oh.
Or not.
For now.
We'll leave that alone for now.
Is this a trap?
I just got this blueberry.
I earned it!
You're not gonna take my health from me!
No, I'm not gonna take it.
I'm gonna stay here.
Oh, shotgun.
Oh my god!
Oh!
That was close!
Shoot.
Okay.
What the heck is this?
What the heck was that?
What?
What's all these sounds?
The
gun just disappeared!
The gun reappeared!
Supercharge is a blueberry hit with the maid magic.
Freaky ghost gun!
Look at all these switches!
Okay, first of all though...
I wanna go back to...
Here.
And see if this is possible.
With the right amount of speed.
Wait.
At some point...
It goes down, it goes...
The yellow key part is a bit BS.
I really skipped on the reload animation for the super shotgun.
It's okay.
Now it's gonna go back up though.
It doesn't even move!
Thanks for the farm, Gryffindor!
The solution is on the corridor outside.
Is it now?
I don't mind if you guys give me hints.
Don't worry about it.
Just don't tell me the exact answer.
The
yellow...
Punch it!
Shoot it!
Wait, so if I go here...
Pop it!
Maybe...
What it's pointed at.
The other side.
It's the same marking though.
The fact that there's not even a sound.
It's the most quiet.
Lick it!
It didn't work.
Press E on it.
Oh my god, I thought I had.
I think I hadn't...
When the...
When the bars were down.
Thank you.
I'm scared of this room.
Let's change the...
Okay.
Someone's gonna come down here.
At some point.
Oh, this is the correct one?
I'm not even pressing some of these.
You failed.
No gun.
What?
What's the method to this madness?
Is there a way to reset it?
Or not?
I see, I see.
But they only give you two shots!
Two tries to get it?
That's crazy.
No reset, sadly.
That's okay.
I think I... that's the plasma gun, right?
I already have it.
Would have been nice to get the ammo for it, though.
One to orient yourself, one to act on it.
That's so...
That's okay.
Alright, we got the blueberry.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
I was changing my gun, you jerk!
I didn't even know there were still guys out here.
I thought I blew them all up.
There's one.
Can I snipe?
Snipe with the shotgun?
Yes, I can.
More!
Oh my god, lots!
Uh-oh.
More rockets, please!
There
we go!
There we go!
This game is so exciting.
So many things change and move at all times.
What's that?
Oh, energy cell packs.
Nice.
Don't fall.
Aww.
Wait.
That was the exit!
Nice!
88% kills.
88% items.
Who did I miss?
50% secrets.
Entering even simpler.
You cackle as the familiarity of the situation occurs to you.
The gateway to the demon's domain was too accessible.
You realize the demons mock you with their invitation.
It does not matter.
The demons spawn like rats.
And you have the great AAA UAC poison they crave.
Your bloodthirsty scream shatters the teleport haze.
Once again, you find yourself amidst...
...
amidstt...
Saving the game.
I keep thinking that Each level is called, bring it on.
Ohhh!
What the hell is that?!
Oh my god!
Ok.
Oh cold!
Cold Cold Cold Cold!
Fire Fire Fire Fire!
Am I even hitting him?
I don't even know.
Got him.
Oh my god.
There's more?
You.
You bitch.
You bitch!
Please die already!
Die!
Oh my god, there's so many!
Coco Demon!
Die, Coco Demon!
Why do you have so much health?
Okay.
This is where the game gets real.
I can tell.
Nice!
Oh, hello.
Are you stuck in here, or...?
Oh my god!
Where did you go from?
Oh, there's a blue... a green berry!
Box of Rockets, nice.
Oh my gosh, I can't see because of the...
corpse of the Coco Demon.
Yeah, fight each other!
Oh, I thought you were dead.
They just won't stop spawning.
Is this just like a...
one of those maps where I just hold out and like...
hope that I don't die?
Can you make chocolate out of a Coco Demon?
Yeah.
Probably.
I think it would taste a little bitter.
Oh, blueberry.
Pretty much, yes.
Okay.
Why is it so yellow?
Oh, there they come.
What was that sound?
Tink, tink, tink, tink.
Metal soundtrack, the foreboding ambiance.
I know, right?
Like, it's...
The change in atmosphere is actually really...
crazy.
Holy moly.
Let's see.
I feel like I can't read chat very much because I'm like...
just waiting for the next spawn.
The next wave to...
What the?
What are these?
What the hell are these?
Oh, those are those metal sounds I was hearing.
The clink, clink, clink, clink.
Ah, okay, okay.
Are they attached to a...
a guy?
Exit?
Is it chat?
Is this real?
Chat?
Hm, yes.
Those deal way more damage than you expect.
I'm glad I avoided it then.
Holy cow.
Oh.
Oh, I should...
Wait.
Go through.
Oh!
Yippee!
Invulnerability wasted.
I wouldn't have used it.
I wouldn't have been able to use it anyway.
Entering the bleeding.
Ooh, carpet.
Yucky.
The doors are really special though.
I like the parts when we, like, leave the ship and actually enter hell, you know?
Oh, chainsaw.
I got it back!
I got it back after all.
Maybe I'll go to the shoddy.
Shoddy, yoddy, yoddy, yoddy.
Plasma gun!
Oh, goodbye!
I hear someone.
Trying to, like, see if I can snipe them from up here.
But I can't.
Save.
Oh, okay.
I'll save.
What the hell?
Shabap, shabap.
I don't wanna go berserker.
Secret item.
Where am I hearing them from though?
I want the upper hand!
But I don't think I will have it.
Oh well.
Oh!
Pickle pop hepburn!
That was down though, wasn't it?
Just now?
Guess this one's a little bit linear.
Oh, my god!
They were on top of each other, so I didn't even notice them.
Did I kill him?
Yeah.
Oh!
Whoa.
Everything moves in this game.
It's kinda crazy.
Yeah.
Let's get the other one.
This one.
Oh!
I noticed you.
It does go down.
But when?
Did I miss my opportunity?
Oh, I don't need it.
Okay, but we know it's there.
We know it's there.
Yeah!
Where's all the guys?
Not that I'm complaining.
Oh!
Whoa!
There's all the guys.
Devil switch.
Pull my devil trigger.
Imps are so funny.
Oh!
Lots of pinkies.
Oh.
Oh, that guy.
Oh, man.
What's a good one?
Maybe...
Rocket launch him.
Ow!
No!
Oh
my god.
Where'd you go?
Pinky?
There.
Oh.
Got him.
I got him.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's another one.
And one more.
And another one.
Where is he?
You are not TF2 soldier.
What does that even mean?
I don't even know what that means.
I've never played Team Fortress.
Did I get everybody?
Am I safe to jump down?
Well, I said safe as, you know, face rocket attacks things.
Why am I such an idiot me?
Why do I always take a rocket to the face?
Oh, I hear more.
I think over there though.
I think I want more shotgun shells.
I'll take the clips too though.
Shotgun.
Oh, okay.
That's here.
Look at this trap.
If this was never a trap to be...
If this was a trap of...
Before, I would still know that this is a trap.
Is there anything else?
I'm trying to look for any...
There's this room.
Blueberry.
Oh, I hear them.
I hear them growling.
Where are you guys?
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Yo, that's so unfair.
That's so unfair.
Alright, I gotta stop being a little baby.
Alright,
I gotta stop being a little baby.
I need lifestyles.
Hell yeah.
What is that key?
Hello?
Can you stop...
Can you like...
Stop roaring and...
I think it was those guys, right?
There's a few more.
I thought we had peace and quiet.
Oh my god, you guys are so annoying.
Oh, it's the pinkies.
There's a pinky.
Okay, we need the yellow key.
Cool.
Easy.
I really want the blueberry.
Should I risk it for the biscuit?
No peace and quiet.
Only busting.
You're so right.
Look at these.
At the place, when I went to...
My sister got married last year.
And when I went to her wedding, the place that she got married at had all these little demon gremlin statues that looked like this.
That was so unserious.
Risk it for the biscuit.
Yeah, yeah.
What's gonna come out, I wonder?
We'll do the chain gun.
What?
I'm so glad I risked it for the biscuit.
Yippee!
Now they're messing with you.
I know, right?
Oh!
I didn't conceal this armor before either.
Nice.
Wait, am I full on shotgun?
Seriously?
Wow.
Okay.
It was up here.
And around the corner.
And through here.
Yellow.
What's that gun over there?
I don't think I've picked that one up yet.
Come here, pancake!
Can't believe Mint's sister married Vlad Dracula.
Oh wait, I can touch this, can't I?
This is just water.
I'm stronger than you.
What is this?
Ah!
Am I moving with the water?
Oh, I am.
That was pretty nice.
Is he gonna attack me?
Eventually he will be able to get me.
No secret behind the water.
What kind of game is this?
Atlantis no nazo statue is on the last floor.
Hold up.
Press that.
Where does this go to?
Oh!
Buck at the top.
Okay.
Where the...
Oh, okay.
What did that do?
Oh!
I thought it said a box of spells for a second.
I was like...
Wow, we got the...
Oh!
I got the BFG!
I didn't mean to shoot it twice.
But...
I guess that worked.
Wait, which one is that?
Seven?
Seven.
The BFG, baby!
Okay.
Well, we pressed...
The one over here.
So let's go back and see what has changed.
What is going to try and kill me now out here?
I'll check from up above.
Wait.
Okay.
I'm waiting for those damn spiders.
As soon as I hear the...
You...
You're not as...
You're not as nice.
Big freaky gun.
What does BFG stand for?
Bustin' Feels Good!
Yeah.
Wait, where...
What did that change at all now?
I pressed the switch.
And, um...
Oh my gosh.
Ugh.
I could plasma him.
Hey, what a way!
You stopped my...
My ammo.
Just stay right there.
EMP!
Where all you guys come from?
Shuba Shuba.
In my head they're saying Shuba Shuba.
Bustin' Feels Good.
Makes me feel good.
It feels good.
I wanted him to get nice and close.
The exit!
Wait.
But...
Have I gotten every guy in here?
I wanna make sure I've killed everything.
No demons left behind.
Is this a secret?
Oh no.
I hear nothing alive.
But sometimes there's sneak.
You know.
Sometimes you can't hear them until you're right up on them.
But it's true, I don't hear anything else.
I do not hear...
Any other...
Noises.
Oh, that's health.
Okay.
Guess I'll leave.
Watch it say 95%...
Oh!
Yippee!
96%!
42% secret.
Terror Core!
Ooh.
Thank you.
Let's save the game.
Level 11.
Wait, how many did you guys say there was?
30?
Maybe I'll stop at 15.
I'm feeling okay, but...
What was that?
Ooh.
There's thunder now and everything.
Scary.
Where you behind here?
Oh, blue key.
Yeah, cause I totally want to go in there.
They're making it really enticing.
You know?
They're making it really enticing to want to go in there.
I hear a lot going on.
It's just...
Yeah.
That one clip complains a lot.
It's just like...
I'm not gonna go in there.
I'm gonna go in there.
Are you sure?
I'm not sure.
It's just...
I don't think I can do it.
I'm not sure.
I think I'm doing it right.
Oh, okay, never mind.
I think it raises and... Oh, okay.
It'll fall eventually.
There we go.
25 regular levels, 4 secret levels, and 3 fun levels.
That can only be accessed through the passwords.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello.
I hear them, but they don't... they're too afraid of me.
A boogie.
It's me.
Actually, I'm afraid of them.
It's so wet.
Why?
Why is it so wet?
Squishy.
Almost
had him.
Got him.
Dummies!
I am getting them, right?
Yeah.
Two slime, four demons.
Ghost brain higher than demon brain.
Actually, is that...
I'm afraid.
I'm afraid of the splash damage.
I think I got one guy down.
Come here.
No, I did not.
Oh, there was one guy down.
I don't want to keep using my shotgun shells because I was running low.
There's a box right here.
I say low.
I said, like, 50s.
But I use two at a time, so it's like...
There we go.
I pressed a demon button.
Does a whole lot of demon nothing.
You can switch to the normal shotgun by pressing three again.
Oh, really?
Oh, this goes down.
Okay.
Hello?
Oh.
Just gonna...
Come on, aim.
I don't feel like dealing with you.
Should I ever consider playing MyHouse.
Oh, I know MyHouse!
It's my little mod with lots of doomcute.
Also, please don't make fun of my name.
My parents don't like me.
Well, I wasn't gonna make fun of it until you said something.
I'm not gonna make fun of you until you tell me not to make fun of you.
Oh.
Oh gosh.
I'm so glad I can see these guys.
Where's the other one?
Where are you?
Oh!
I think I got him.
Armor?
What if we ask you to make fun of us?
What then?
Um...
Then it's no fun.
I mean...
I don't know.
This has got to be like a balance, right?
What's that sound?
OK.
I will come back here.
Eventually.
Probably.
I have not gone to this side.
Wait.
I'm guessing... OK.
Run!
I would hate it if you made fun of me.
Totally.
Oh, I don't even need this.
I'm such an idiot.
Red key.
This is where we came from.
Yes.
OK.
Where do I go?
I'm full on rockets.
I'm full on a lot of stuff.
Actually, the most I think I need is...
is shotgun shells.
But I'm not low.
Hmm.
I would totally hate it.
Why would you?
You guys then will use it against me.
If I make fun of you, you'll be like...
She hates us!
If I make fun of you, then you'll be like...
She really hates us!
You'd be so sad.
Just pressing everything that I can.
Just...
Just roofing every wall that's possible.
Prove that you don't hate us, then.
How can I prove that?
Oh.
Oh, I found...
I found a blueberry.
What do you want me to do to...
to prove this to you?
I'll show you.
You son of a...
I think I got him.
Yeah.
Loser.
Oh, there's a key over there.
Yo, they were cheating.
They were!
Yellow key.
Okay.
Will this lower that key?
For me?
No.
What's this go...
Oh!
Look at that.
Nice.
Can I shoot this?
Oh.
Nope.
Just like Doom 2.
This game is so evil!
I know you don't hate us.
Really?
I'm not doing my job well enough, then.
I need to try harder.
Where...
Where was that?
In here?
Here.
Was there anything else here?
I think I hear another one probably on the other side.
Oh, yeah.
Because there's a blueberry here.
How do I...
Hmm...
How do I get this blueberry?
Let's try the other side.
Oh.
Wait...
Where the hell am I?
Hmm...
Oh, here?
How do I get to it?
Can't wait for you to go on your hater training arc.
I'm a hater.
That's me.
Umm...
Where... where... do I go?
I'm gonna keep the chaingun up.
Well, okay, we got the yellow key.
That's all we need for now.
It's okay if I can't get to it.
Which... yellow door was... this is red door.
Yellow door.
Oh, this map.
Raiders?
Hello!
Thank you for the raid!
Right back, thanks for the gift!
Who raided me?
Hello!
Thank you!
I'm playing Doom.
Doom...
Doom 64.
From the Nintendo 64.
Maybe I'm hearing this.
Where was the other yellow door though?
Guys, I'm so lost.
VGI!
Thanks for the gift!
Is... is that it?
I'm so lost.
I don't know where to go.
Red door.
Okay.
Oh, that scared me.
Up, I think.
I'm trying to see... okay.
I'm just gonna follow a map.
We know that we've killed most of the guys in this area, so...
Why is this map so...
You know...
Why?
Okay, let's queue.
Let's queue out.
Where am I supposed to go?
Ducky, thank you for the gift!
Simba, welcome back!
You hate us, so you think about us, right?
Oh, that's... that's...
That's the logic we're using.
Upstairs in those catwalks.
Okay.
So, up in here.
Up in here?
No, I pressed that.
Oh, this is where I said I needed the yellow key!
Oh, I'll get it later!
Come on!
Okay, let's try that again.
Let's jump to the next...
Okay.
Come on, Simba!
Whoa, what's this?
It's like a...
It's like a set of enemies.
I'm like a...
I
said I was going to win.
I made it!
I'm going to win!
I hate Payne and Elemental so much!
I hate those guys so much!
Is there anything over here?
There's so many little areas that look like they could hold secrets.
I hear another one.
Unless that's a pickle.
Hmm.
Okay.
Now we have the red key so we can go all the way back.
All the way back.
This direction?
What is that?
Was that just doors closing?
Okay.
Be on your lookout everybody.
Be on a lookout for...
Wait.
No.
I need to go downstairs.
Oh!
There he is!
Gosh.
I won't be able to watch live because I'm working overtime!
Oh no!
But I'm super excited to see you work your way through the Outer Wilds DLC and the VODs.
Good luck and have fun!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh!
This is where they kill these guys!
Ha ha ha!
At Off-Kai, Atara and I were actually visited by one of the devs.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Come on!
Where'd you go?
And he was just... and he wrote me a note.
He was like, by the way, you know, there's still the DLC for...
For...
Outer Wilds, if you ever play it.
Yeah, Jeffrey!
How did you guys know?
He loves VTubers.
He's so nice.
Zero items!
Zero secrets!
Oof.
Alter, okay.
So I was just like, you know what?
Yeah, you're right, Jeffrey.
I gotta do the DLC.
So...
Yeah, and then I was just like, why not?
Why not?
Why don't I just do it?
What's stopping me?
Nothing's stopping me.
Myself, I'm stopping me.
There's a secret exit here.
Can you find it?
There is?
Is it in the tree?
Sounds like cats meowing.
Oh!
Hold on!
Let me make sure that pause is okay.
Pause!
Give me one second, guys.
She did want out.
I didn't notice.
Oh, I feel so bad.
She wanted out.
I didn't notice.
She probably wanted to go, like, eat or...
Go to the bathroom.
Don't forget to save.
Oh, thank you.
Oh!
Sorry if you can hear my crunch.
Is this water that will kill me?
No, it's not.
It's just dirty, poopy water.
Nasty.
Oh, God.
She ate pies.
Oh, I see you up there.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
My health!
You stupid...
Oh, it's that guy.
No wonder.
I wonder if I can take him down.
Me-ow-ow-wo.
Hold on.
No spamming, please, but thank you.
May I offer you a blueberry in this trying time?
Yes, please.
I can't tell if I'm getting it or not.
Oh shoot.
Die
already!
Just die already!
Oh dang it.
Wasting rockets.
Die already!
Why can't I aim at you anymore?
Finally!
Good moly!
Oh I got health.
Oh my gosh I haven't had to collect regular health in so long.
Dodge, dip, duck.
This map is...
This is like...
It feels kind of Castlevania.
It's kind of funny.
Blueberry!
Probably shouldn't just press random buttons but...
You know.
Wow!
Redberry!
What's that one do?
I don't think I've ever seen the redberry before.
This map is bonkers.
I'm already so lost.
I went through...
I guess I should drop down and kind of look around somewhere else but...
Thank god.
Over here.
Whoa!
Wow!
This is so cool!
Take that.
Apparently there was a secret exit at the beginning but...
I just chose to ignore it.
Redberry equals partial invisibility.
Tree!
At least the trees aren't here to kill me.
I love this little cave.
It's so cool.
Should have known something would be in there.
And I did.
I did know.
Cozy cave.
The demons got it made.
They've got such a cool little thing going on here.
Oh, but there's nothing extra special over here.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
That was close.
Oh!
This is actually a door!
Health
bonus.
All the ambient lighting is so fun.
You're a gamer.
Nice dodges.
Thank you!
Oh!
Look at that.
Plasma gun!
Uh oh.
What am I pressing?
I'm scared.
What am I...
What am I inviting into the open, you know?
Box of bullets.
I'll take it.
And...
Oh, that's nothing.
That's just some pile of meat.
The music is so scary.
I'm not gonna lie.
I really don't like it, actually.
Like, I like it.
Like, it's spooky and that's why I like it, but I don't like it.
Kinda scared.
I'm kinda scared, you guys.
Oh.
It's unsettling.
Yeah, like, the meowing is really...
I don't...
I don't like it.
Meow.
Why is there demon meat on the ground, I wonder?
Sounds like a baby crying.
Yeah!
That's what I mean by the cat noises.
I guess...
There's an exit over there.
Is that where the exit is?
Okay.
Good to know.
That's where we go.
What did those switches do?
I don't know.
Oh, this game is such a mystery.
Meow.
Can I run to this?
What?
Oh, I can.
Cool.
Ah!
This area.
Yeah, yeah.
Shut up.
Oh!
We got a red key.
I'm hearing something.
Oh!
I got him.
All right.
Red key.
Where?
Ah!
Yeah!
Imp!
Come back here, imp!
And there's...
Oh!
There's a pinky down there.
Somewhere.
What?
Thank you for the red key.
Oh!
Red!
Sorry.
I can't...
Why did YouTube change it to white on white text, man?
Don't understand.
Oh!
Look at the invisibility.
Nice.
Um...
I, uh...
Rose went and sampled the cat.
Ah!
Oh, my God!
I was invisible!
How did you find me?
This is messed up.
Messed up!
Thank you for the red!
Thank you!
I'm gonna go down here.
Grab some more shotgun shells.
And then the...
Get the pinky here.
There he goes.
Oh!
This is the...
Isn't this the beginning?
Yeah.
This is the beginning.
This is where we teleported away.
We didn't go anywhere like over here.
Jay, thanks for the vibe gifter!
Wowee!
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Oh, someone else is shooting at me from somewhere.
Not quite sure where.
Blueberry.
Where are they shooting?
Oh.
Don't walk away!
He was like, I'm not even gonna look.
I know they're gonna hit you.
I don't even need to see.
Come back and fight me.
Like a man.
Hola, mint.
Hola!
It's been two spooky months.
I know!
I was just thinking that.
I was like, wow.
I can't believe it's been like two months since I've... since I've come back to streaming.
Already.
Feels so much longer and shorter at the same time, right?
It's partial invisibility.
Like being partially pregnant.
What?
I don't think you can be partial.
I don't even think you can be impartial.
I don't think so.
Oh my God.
The cross.
Spooky.
We're almost at a year, baby.
How do I get...
Wait.
Okay.
So we got the red key.
So where was a red door?
I don't remember.
Let's teleport back up here.
Okay.
And figure it out.
I said...
Oh.
Hey, you.
Don't run away.
Yeah, that's right.
Can't believe it's been two years, boss.
Oh, here.
Oh, I'm lost.
In the sauce.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh my God.
Hah.
Holy cow.
Just came up and I didn't even know he was going to be there.
Hiyah.
Nice.
Door's stuck.
Anybody in there?
Plasma gun?
Plasma ammo?
Oh, sacrifice!
This seems like kind of a big deal.
What is this?
Wait!
I got unholy fire...
Wait, what is this?
I thought it was like a human body!
Does this use my health?
What does this...?
The Unmaker.
Ow!
I obliterated him!
It unmakes things.
What does it use for ammo?
Really powerful energy weapon.
Let's go!
How do I get up there?
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
The Baron scared me.
Through here, maybe?
Got it.
Okay.
Yellow... skull... yellow door...
Where is the yellow door?
Yellow door...
I can't avoid it.
I got a... I got a berry.
Blueberry.
Wait, so what number is that?
Okay, it's 8.
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow!
Okay, yellow door.
Yellow door.
Is it friendly fire if ghosts fight demons like this?
Oh!
No!
We're completely different, ghosts and demons.
Ghosts are way superior.
Obviously.
Yellow door...
Do you guys remember?
So close yet so far from the secret exit.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
That's why it's a secret.
If I don't get it, I don't get it.
Sometimes I do.
Sometimes I have a stroke of genius.
Maybe... Okay.
How do I get to there?
Okay, hold on.
Let's go back this way.
Let's teleport back up because I do maybe want to try through that exit.
And sometimes just a stroke.
Yeah!
Love when I have just a stroke.
Okay, maybe I go through here.
So yellow.
Oh!
Of course it's so yellow in here.
Eight.
I want to use it on you.
Oh, it misses very easily though.
It misses extremely easily.
Yeah!
Unbirth him!
Happy unbirthday to you, Baron.
Is this timed?
It's just so funny that they were like, nope, you can't get it unless you kill that guy.
And it was like...
If you sneak up behind her...
Oh, I missed someone.
I wonder who.
Zero secrets.
I love M64.
Thanks for the super chat.
Baby mode moment.
I guess so.
Wow!
I love that thing right there.
The decor is immaculate.
Are we on what?
13 now?
Oh!
Come here!
The sound is on.
It's really echo-y.
Hmm.
Oh!
Lots of...
Uh-oh!
I hear those things again.
Oh!
I hear the clanks.
I heard it.
Hmm.
Yeah, this level...
Uh-oh.
What am I gonna have a...
Am I in for a bad time?
Am I in for it?
I'm afraid of them.
I don't know where they come from.
I don't think I really need to even go in here though, right?
We'll just, uh...
Cruise in for a bruising.
Oh!
Ow!
I thought I dodged that!
Wait!
Where did it come from?
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Okay.
We'll shoot.
Check out...
Immorifer's Doom64 Discord server.
Oh!
I don't know if I'll join that.
But if anybody is interested and wants to...
join more Doom stuff, then they can do that.
But thank you!
Hmm.
Not yet.
Oh!
I need a red key.
Uh.
In here?
Why can't I pick this up?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Ugh!
Oh my god.
That was so close.
I almost just died.
I almost just fell in.
Oh.
Didn't even see that guy over there.
What the...
Okay.
Hey, hey, hey.
So, what's going on?
So, I can't really see you.
Stop.
Can you teabag in this game?
You can't even jump.
I don't think you can teabag.
Wasted opportunity, truly.
I guess we'll save that for later.
Any other pillars that have any pushy buttons?
Any demon buttons?
Greetings from Chile!
Also first time watching, hello!
Thanks for watching!
Thanks for joining.
We're having a Doomtastic day.
I hope you are as well.
Where did that little...
I heard the clanks.
Okay, I'm just gonna go in.
Yeah, I didn't even...
Oh, there it is!
Okay.
And it doesn't lift this up.
But maybe it lifts up the other one.
Woo!
There we go.
Oh, no.
Wait, no, it didn't.
That didn't do at all what I thought it would.
What the heck?
You guys are so funny.
Oh my god, I thought that was a person standing there.
That freaked me out for a second.
Wait, where the hell am I?
Oh, shoot.
Okay, there's a lot going on in here.
Okay.
There's a...
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
There's a lot going on here.
Take it easy.
Shoot and dodge, shoot and dodge.
Shoot and punch.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, clutch.
Shoot and dodge.
I know there's more of you.
Where are...
Where are you?
Shoot and doji.
No.
I mean, I wish.
I wish.
Jeez.
I don't know much about fate.
But I know shoot and doji.
I think I saw another one.
Well, I know.
There.
Where are you?
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Where?
Oh.
Oh my god, there's still so many.
Okay, one more.
One more.
I could save him for later, but...
I like to clean up an area, you know?
Mint and shoot and doji have a win?
Oh my gosh, so embarrassing.
I'm too shy.
Okay, screw it.
I don't care.
I'll come back.
I'll get them when we get there.
Wait.
Which is right now.
Apparently.
Wait, there's more?
Oh.
Where else are they coming from?
I'm too shy for that outfit, you guys.
Green berry.
Oh, no.
How do I get to him?
Ask and you shall receive.
May I have a berry?
May I have a bite?
This one's kind of spooky looking.
Shuten has a maid outfit of her own?
She does?
Why have I never seen this before?
Or maybe I have and I just forgot.
Red key.
Okay, good.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
We don't have the blue key.
I just noticed all the little gargoyles are staring at me.
Why are you guys so obsessed with me?
Stop looking.
Let's see.
Is there anything?
I'm looking for any buttons to push.
That aren't my own.
This game do be pushing my buttons though.
Wait.
Can I go back?
Oh.
Okay.
I can go back up.
La la la la.
Whoa!
He just came from the wall.
Oh, it's here.
Should we try for it?
I might die.
Here, I'm going to save.
Save game.
Okay.
Okay,
I wrote a little mistake.
Let's make sure that...
Oh.
Run is on.
Yippee!
Um,
I don't think I remember...
Okay, this is the beginning.
I don't remember pushing any buttons, but...
And we don't have the red key.
Okay.
I'm going to go to this one over there, buh.
No, okay, so that's still not open.
And here...
Again.
No.
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh!
Stop it!
Wait, where was it again?
Wait, now I'm lost actually.
Okay, hold on.
Don't shoot at me.
This is the entrance.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
So we didn't go this way.
I could probably get the green berry from here.
Let me get the green berry.
Invulnerability!
And let's hurry.
Are you Dooming?
I can't see anything actually.
Oh, god.
I'm Dooming!
But I can't...
Oh, gosh.
I can't see anything while I'm Dooming.
Oh,
god.
Oh, god.
Oh.
Let's do this.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Another one.
Yeah!
Everybody okay?
Everybody good?
Un-make those barons.
Uh-oh.
When does it end?
Okay.
Okay!
Kind of a beat.
Indiana Jones time.
I sure hope I didn't miss something.
Probably did, but...
Oh, my throat is really starting to hurt.
Okay, so I do need to go out here.
Okay.
Got it.
Let's try again.
I took minimal damage!
264 is some of the most deadly traps since Plutonia.
Not Plutonia.
Okay.
Blue key acquired.
How do I get out of here?
I don't know.
Uh, exit?
Exit doku diskar?
Where the heck is the exit?
Unless I... I have to...
Ugh...
Does it only open?
Nope.
Oh, shit.
I'll take darts over chaingunners and arch-viles?
Maybe.
Hug the wall.
Okay.
Oh!
La la la.
It was here the whole time!
That's so funny.
Maybe I should have used the berry for that moment.
I don't live, but I do learn.
Alright, so now we got the blue key.
So...
Blue was...
Ugh!
I might have to make this my last level though, because...
My throat is really killing me.
My throat is killing me.
And I...
I must confess...
I'm still sick-y.
Still sick-y.
Okay.
Very cool.
Oh!
You're eating through this game?
I think it's because I chose an easier level.
Which I thought was normal.
I really thought it was normal.
I didn't want to play on easy mode.
Ah!
Where am I hearing?
Pinky.
Right there.
Are you finishing in one stream?
No, no, no.
I have it on my schedule for finishing...
Um...
Next Sunday.
Same time.
I think.
I think I have put it at the same time.
I can't remember actually.
But um...
I ate these things!
But uh...
I... I...
Could have...
If I was feeling better, I would play it in one stream.
Oh, wait a second.
Oh!
Wait...
I thought I was feeling better though.
Holy cow!
Ow!
He was camping me for real!
The libraries...
Oh!
Oh my goodness.
I'll unalive you though.
Unbirth you?
What was it?
Woo!
That was close.
We're in the library.
I love the decor.
I love these tall, like, Nosferatu-looking...
Goofy guys here.
And they're every...
Ow!
And they're everywhere.
Oh, it's unbirth.
Oh, okay.
Unbirth you!
Oh!
Another
little maze going on in here.
Oh!
Never mind.
Oh, it's unmake!
Everyone's giving me wrong information!
Well, you guys kept saying, I'm Bertha, I'm Bertha.
I was like, oh!
It must be that one.
Ew, I'm hearing something.
Unless it's just the ambience.
You didn't pin the new schedule on Twitter?
Yes, I know, I know.
I haven't posted it on Twitter yet because I...
I uh...
Oops, ouch!
I um...
I was trying to spread out my tweets a little bit.
I don't know if you've noticed, but like...
If I'm just like, oh I have to tweet about...
Like my waiting room or something, then I'll hold off on posting something else.
Thank you!
Do you even know what unbirth means?
No?
Wait...
Wait, no I don't.
What does it mean?
I thought it was like...
I think of... whenever I think of unbirthing...
I think of...
Alice in Wonderland, they say a very merry unbirthday.
So I just think of it as that.
No...
Don't look it up, okay?
You guys scare me sometimes.
Red key!
Yeah, they go...
A very merry unbirthday to...
A very merry unbirthday to me.
To me!
A very merry unbirthday to....
Oh shoot.
I hear him...
Oh.
Oh, he's right here.
Were you here the whole time?
You're supposed to turn around.
You're supposed to... Stop circling.
You're supposed to... You're ruining my plan.
It's a fetish term.
Think of it as like a reverse of birth.
A very merry unbirthing to you two.
Stop!
Now I know what it means, I think!
I actually don't know what it means though.
So do you pretend like... Do you pretend to be like the placenta?
And stuff?
I wonder.
How do I get... Oh, here.
Alright, red door was...
I mean, we were all there once.
Some people just want to return to...
To baby.
Where was a red door?
Or was it a red switch?
I can't... Oh!
Red door!
This looks like a boss area.
Ow!
There we go.
Is that it?
Was it just that guy?
And some fire in the middle?
Uh-oh.
Wait, I didn't mean to pick this one.
Let's pick the un...
Unmaker.
I'll remember its name from now on.
I'm sorry.
The design of this room is awesome, right?
It's so cool.
Okay.
Box of rockets.
Shotgun.
Did I grab everything?
I can't... My health is...
Okay.
Cool.
Okay, mister.
They locked you in there for a reason, I think.
Nobody likes you.
Nobody invited you.
Yippee!
That was 100% our fault.
Yeah, it was.
There's an indie game called The Citadel.
Oh, yes, I do know The Citadel.
It's classic Doom with hot anime girls.
I do know it, actually.
Unbirthing.
One word.
Shlurp.
I'm sorry.
I don't know what's going on.
100% kills.
72% items.
Zero secrets.
So sad.
The Eye of the Storm.
I know that.
I said that was my last game.
I just want to take that guy out while he's not paying attention.
Okay.
Okie-dokie.
I think I am going to...
finish here, though.
And then we'll finish...
next week.
Mint knows The Citadel based.
The Citadel is also cursed in a way I never expected.
Really?
I've only heard of it.
I don't know much about it.
But Iron Lung has the same musical composer.
Is this game?
Maybe that's why all the ambiance is really good.
Gosh, my nose is so itchy right now.
I hate being sick.
I hate that my throat is hurting all the time.
I hate that I'm still not recovered.
Goodbye.
Wiping today.
Ghosty.
Hope you're feeling better soon.
Thank you.
It's 4 AM.
Can I finally go to bed?
Yes, Android.
Go to bed.
Of course you would be here for Doom.
Tomorrow I'll be doing DLC of...
I decided to do...
Rather than like splitting it up like one...
Part one week and one part the next week.
Since I...
It's...
I played Outer Wilds somewhat recently.
And so the information is still kind of fresh in my brain.
But I want to play...
I wanted to play...
While it's still fresh in my...
In my head.
So yeah.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you guys!
Thanks for hanging out.
Thanks for returning to Doom Mint.
My podcast merch just arrived.
It's so good.
Thank you, Doomed Fireman!
Thank you, Marilyn.
Glad you're having fun with Doom 64.
I know that you will love Doom 3 when you get around to it.
I hope you feel better soon.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, yeah.
Doom 3.
And then...
I do...
Like I said, I do want to play like Doom Eternal.
I want to get to...
The...
The new Doom really inspired me.
So I'm like...
But I'm not a Doom player unless I play all the Dooms.
If you're planning on revisiting Doom or Doom 2, will you be willing to play them on Brutal Doom or even Project Brutality?
Hmm...
I'll think about it.
I think I need to get a bit better before I up my level too much though.
You're a Doomer?
Name all the Doom games.
I'm a Doom scroller.
I'm a Doomer.
I'm a...
I'm a Boomer.
Oh my god, I wonder if I...
I wonder if I...
So I'm...
I wonder if I still have that.
I used to have...
The Doom logo but it said Boomer instead of Doomer.
I wonder if...
I should still have it.
I don't think I would delete it.
Sorry if you can hear me crunching.
Oh my god.
Oh, I do still have it!
Me!
Boomer.
Can we call you...
The what guy?
The phantom guy?
Yeah, perfect.
Boomer.
Boomer eternally.
Aren't we all boomers at this point?
Well, get it?
Because I'm a...
BOOMER.
Get it?
Because I say boo.
Because I'm a ghost.
I'm not a boomer like you guys.
I'm a...
BOOMER.
Today you are the baby mode boomer.
No!
Stop judging my baby mode!
I really thought...
I really truly thought that I was playing on normal.
That's okay.
I'm still having fun with it.
Unsubbed.
STOP!
You still need to play the 62 Doom games.
Between 2 and 64.
Oh boy.
Yup.
I guess I'm a... I'm a Doom YouTuber now.
I'm a Doom VTuber now.
Drop!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
I would stick around and talk more, but my throat is really starting to hurt.
So...
I think I am gonna call it here.
I hope you guys had a good weekend.
And um...
Sorry that I couldn't stream this yesterday.
But uh...
Glad that I could stream it today.
I've got a full full week ahead of us.
So um... lots of stuff.
Aren't there 61 games between 2 and 64?
I'm not a scientist.
Coyote Actual!
Welcome back for two months!
Thank you!
Mmm.
But hopefully...
I'll be feeling better this week.
And all that fun stuff.
So I'll rest lots.
I will.
I'll rest lots so that I can feel better.
And um...
Have lots of fun with all my streams this week!
Yippee!
Minto, I got some good news and some bad news.
Bad news, I broke my wrist.
Oh no!
Good news, I get to watch you live more often.
Yippee!
Are you okay?
No, Mr. McVeigh.
I hope you feel better too.
Let's have a good week!
This week, everybody!
Yippee!
Thank you, Minto.
No, thank you!
Otsu, Minto!
Otsu, Bustin'.
Otsu, Boomer.
Otsu, Doomer.
And I'll see you guys tomorrow for...
Outer Wilds.
Echoes... Echoes of the Eye?
Eye of the Echoes?
Echoes of the Eye.
Echo...
Can't remember the name.
Otsu, Minto!
Otsu, Bustin'.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I'm gonna go rest my throat now.
It's like right...
It's like not my throat.
It's like the back of my mouth.
It hurts so bad.
Okay.
Bye-bye!
Thanks for watching, you guys!
Thanks for hanging out!
Bye-bye!
Thank you for the super chat!
Tobas, I hope you had a good day!
I
hope you had a good day!
Thank you everybody.
See you guys tomorrow!
Bye-bye!
Thank you!